Stick to the trail.
This goddamn weather.
Been two days or more like this now.
Oh, it has to blow over soon.
Careful over this bridge here.
I can't believe we lost Davey, too.
He's the last one, Arthur.
No more.
We need to get those people warm and fed.
At least we don't need to worry about Pinkerton's tailing us in this.
A couple more days.
We'll be on the other side.
You need to help me pick the others back up.
You're the only one I can rely on to stay strong right now.
We got fire and shelter.
That's a start.
Get a move on, Arthur.
There you are.
Just stay close.
So, do you think it was a trap in Blackwater?
That many men?
They knew we were coming.
There was money on that boat, all right.
Lots of it.
I stashed what we took with all our money in town right before we fled.
Wait.
Is that someone coming towards us?
You up ahead.
Who's there?
Whoa.
Micah.
Gentlemen.
Found anything?
I think so.
Found a little homestead down that way.
Okay.
Anyone home?
Sure.
Place is blazing with light and noise.
Sounded like a party.
Let's go see.
Follow me.
How's Davey doing?
He didn't make it.
Nor did little Jenny.
That's too bad.
Davey was a real fighter.
Both of them calendar boys is.
Or was.
Yeah.
And Mac, Sean?
We don't know.
Quite a business.
I'm glad you're all right, Micah.
Always.
Ask him if he's seen John.
Hey, have you seen John, Micah?
Didn't see much of anything once this storm came in.
He hasn't seen anything.
You're going to have to wait until you see him.
He'll be fine.
Things always turn out right for that boy.
I hope Mac and Sean are still out there somewhere, too.
Hey, Arthur, let me take the rear.
You move up.
Are you sure about this, Micah?
Mr. Morgan.
I never thought I would be able to do this.
I never thought I would be so pleased to see your face.
Been kind of lonely out here.
Where's everyone else?
Old mining camp back up to hell.
Goddamn.
Cuddled around a fire waiting for Daddy to put food on the table.
Said it before, we got too many mouths to feed.
Well, we got a few less now, so you should be happy.
That ain't fair, Arthur.
I earned my share.
Okay, let's keep it down now, gentlemen.
It's just up ahead.
Snuff and stash those lanterns, boys.
Best you two lie low on this.
Hey!
Okay, let's head down there.
Let's hitch up here.
Watch out!
Yeah.
Let me do the talking.
We don't want to scare these folks.
Someone's having fun in there.
You two, get yourself out of sight.
One lonely man is a lot less intimidating than three nasty-looking degenerates.
Arthur, in that cattle shed on the left.
Micah, get down behind that wagon in front.
Hello?
Shut up, Billy.
Excuse me.
Hello?
Oh, uh, hello, friend.
What you want?
I am very sorry.
Too disturbing.
I don't want to disturb you.
Uh, my friends and I, well, we got into some trouble up the way.
Lost in the storm.
Ah, gentlemen.
We can't help you, mister.
I got folks dying on the trail.
Arthur, we got a problem.
Folks.
There's a corpse right here.
Now, I just need some cans of food or something.
I hear you.
Just keep your eyes on.
Please.
You should go now, buddy.
Over there!
More of them!
It's an android!
There's another one shooting from the window!
Back there, Morgan!
Come on, you stupid son of a bitch!
Goddamn bastards!
You're dead!
Now!
I ain't lyin' over this!
We've got a r訂er!
See ya, ARCHER!
There ya go, good buster.
거나
This whole bastard communism black hat it is.
Wanna get did you?
No way!
Arthur, I said I'd handle this!
Didn't seem to be going too well.
Goddamn O'Driscoll boys here! Why?
I don't know. Maybe same reason as us.
Micah, go bring the horses closer to the house. Arthur, let's go search the cabin.
Smells like a party in here.
Turn the place upside down. Grab as many supplies as you can.
We need the essentials. Food, medicine, whiskey.
Oh, I'm starving.
You should eat... something now.
Get your strength up for the ride back.
I'll be right back.
O'Driscoll's. I don't believe it.
It's a strange one, Arthur.
Hey, maybe they're hiding up here too.
There's a big price on comb O'Driscoll's had.
Nearly as big as the one on yours.
Wantin' comb dead is about the only thing me and Uncle Sam agree on.
I've got a feeling this place is gonna be a mess.
We're gonna have to find a way to get out of here.
This place is dry and warm. We could maybe move the women and Jack down here.
Maybe. We'll see how they are when we get back. I don't really want us to split up.
I've got a feeling this place is gonna be a mess.
I don't really want us to split up.
Maybe we should just leave.
I'm not sure how we'll get out of here.
We should just go back.
I'm scared.
See if you can take the hat off by you don't stab them.
You just have to cause some trouble.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I had to go find the Flannery.
Now shouldn't that give him good time as a young Link?
Thank Oddy for when.
You better, thank you.
You yourself.
Thanks, I was eyes on.
Why, I wish I could have gotten this out by myself for taking some time off.
Batch, this is Ed.
Let's hope you avoid the Fang Wins.
I'm gonna break your neck!
What's going on?
Now this guy just jumped me!
Oh ho, didn't he?
Now...
Sneaky little bastard.
Should I kill him?
No... not yet.
Find out what they're doing here, and where Colm is.
Oh this son of a bitch will talk.
There's Colm O'Driscoll.
With the others... at an old mining camp southwest of here, near the lake.
What are you bastards doing?
Why are you up here?
We're fixing to rob some train.
Gonna blow the tracks.
I don't know more than that, I swear.
Well I would say it looks like you have this, Arthur.
Do what you want with him, I don't care.
But bring that horse when you're done.
I don't know anything else.
Please.
I'm sorry.
I did this kind of thing because I wanted you to.
I didn't want my life going down the drain.
We shouldn't have done that.
Says I'll come back.
We'll have a tail...
I don't know that.